let's see let's go to our caller from
the 911 four area code caller from 994
hi Dave I love your show thank you like
this all the time only my name is Rory
I'm a girl did you say Rory yeah wasn't
ours all right what's going on Rory yeah
so I'm just curious I am from New York
but I live in Florida now and I have to
be honest with you even as like a white
female
I had trouble voting what does that mean
I'm I went I went to the poll like I
went to a polling Center where I thought
I was allowed what's not allowed had to
like leave okay but let's step through
it let's step through it so did you why
did you go to that polling center as
opposed to any other um that's where I
voted the last time in 2016 perfect so
you had voted there previously so us and
you hadn't moved since so you figured
I'm sure I'm voting in the same place
right got it okay you fry up a nine you
say you weren't allowed what did they
say well it wasn't
early voting I I was supposed to be
early voting so like when I went there
the original time I was early voting so
it's not actually so usually for people
who don't know this when people are
early voting sometimes a city that might
have 50 places where people vote there
might only be eight that's early voting
and you can go to them no matter where
in the city you live but then on
Election Day you have to go to your
polling place correct yes
so fine I did but on my way in what I
was waiting online everyone was telling
me no it's fine as long as you have ID
it's okay to vote here why is there so
much like disconnect between like people
like voting and not voting you know Rory
I mean it sounds like here it's
like I mean listen with with total peace
and love it sounds like it sounds like
you didn't immediately realize that
early voting can happen at any location
but you have to go to your polling place
on Election Day and it seems like the
people in line just gave you wrong
information right I mean is it true - is
it fair to say that if you just went to
your designated polling place on
Election Day you would have been able to
vote I made it what a bit ya know and I
did look afterwards guys but what I'm
saying is the information nothing like
the whole like like it's like it seems
like very like great like I heard it
through the grapevine kind of stuff
going on people who were saying I heard
you can vote here no matter where you
live in the city exactly yeah well
that's people being on in fact that's
not anything new that I mean we we
should your first mistake was listening
to those people in line I think well I
mean like three seconds but anyway I
don't know the disconnect between the
information that we're getting and like
the information that's real it's a
little troubling yeah but you didn't get
any faulty information from any a voting
authority right oh no you just went to
the wrong place and then deeper in line
told you to stay there and it's just
like I don't know Facebook man
Facebook's a problem all right Rory
thank you for the call I really
appreciate it
all right take care and on that note
we're out of time for calls thanks to
everybody who called thanks to everybody
that I unfortunately didn't get to
possible livestream later today though
could be an opportunity to call and
again we will take calls again